these are my disclosures here. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to run through all the
Bleximendib data that we have thus far. Fortunately, when you go second, you can
completely blow by the mechanism of action slide. So thank you, Gus. I appreciate you speaking of
that. Bleximendib is a little bit unique, and so I'm going to try to explain how it's a little
different possibly from any other Mennon inhibitors. What we see is that with Bleximendib,
it has a flexible tail, and that flexible tail and the way it's positioned adds to a little bit
how it has a biochemical potency and sort of how it's binding, and it's really the most potent
binder of all of the different Mennon inhibitors. Now, in general, when you think about this,
it's an oral inhibitor similar to the rest of these. It's the most potent, as we can see from
the different mechanisms that it binds. But more importantly, I think that as I go down to the last
statement, because I want to just focus on this, it does have some antiproliferative activity against
some of the mutants, and I'm going to really focus on that a little bit towards the end of this. But
seeing preclinical activity, somebody earlier today talked about the possibility about what do
we do with these after transplant, and what do we do with these Mennon inhibitors. Bleximendib has
some data where it may show some enhanced T-cell toxicity, so there may be some enhancement
post-transplant in that regard. And there's also some preclinical data where you see
synergy with FLIT3 inhibitors and also with the azoven combination, which is what pushes us to
this point. The phase one trial, I'm going to really just briefly touch on this. You can see in the
Carolina blue that the NPM1 was a little bit less than the KMT2A that we're highlighting this. But
that really doesn't have much to do with the safety aspect. What really is focused on the
safety aspect is a degree of neutropenia. And so in the higher doses, they really had significant
neutropenia, which really was the dose-limiting toxicity. And so the 100 milligram dose was the
more stable and better tolerated dose. Now, the efficacy was really similar between these two,
which is why the 90-100
milligram dosing is the standard dosing at the time. And you can see that it really affected both,
not just the NPM1 group, but also the KMT2A group. And that's where, I think, why it's going with both
mutations. They came forward with what's called the 1002 study, which is really an ambitious group
of studies that look at doublets and triplets in both relapsed refractory and in newly diagnosed
treatment. And what we can see,
and this is comparing just the low-intensity treatments. I didn't think I moved, sorry.
The low-intensity treatments combining Blexi plus Ven as a doublet versus the triplet, which you can
see. And it's sort of the way I think about this is kind of like what we did with the FLT3 inhibitors,
where we had Ven gilt, and then we had triplet that you can see now. And I'm putting these together,
which I know is statistically illegal or not what people would want to do,
but the bottom line is I only got seven minutes, so we're just going to flow.
When you look at these, what I think is important when you compare the toxicity with the doublet and
the triplet, there's really not a significant difference in the toxicity, as you can see in
circle. Similar rates of neutropenia, similar rates of thrombocytopenia, it is notable. It's
a really small population in doublet. But I think comparing toxicity, you can see there wasn't a significant
toxicity. But when you look at the response rates, there's really a much more significant
CRC or CCR rate, excuse me, with the triplet as opposed to the doublet. And really it's impressive
that you're seeing a 75% CCR rate with the newly diagnosed population, which I think is important,
because it's a newly diagnosed population that includes the NPM1 and the KMT2A,
even though it was more shaded to the NPM1 population.
They've also looked at this with intensive chemotherapy with 7+3,
and what you can see is that really very nice responses with minimal toxicity. You're looking
at the KMT2A group, which is really the more aggressive group that we have a harder time
curing. Long-term survival is about 30%, but you're seeing response rates about 90%. You're seeing the
similar response rate in the NPM1. 80% of these patients achieve MRD negativity. So I think it's very important
that you're not just getting good responses, but you're seeing deep responses, which will hope to
lead towards better responses to transplant down the road for that KMT2A category.
All right. So this is the interesting, I think the more interesting slides that I got from
Wallace Bourgeois over at Scott Armstrong's lab in Dana-Farber at
Children's. And Gus touched on this a little bit, where they were looking at how these five different
menin inhibitors bound and more particularly where they bound and where they actually linked to the
menin group and what they did. And so if you're going to pay attention to one slide, this is the
one to look up from your computer to look at. What they did was they actually created, they not only
looked at the review menin mutations, which they knew, but they looked at the different mutations
that they hypothesized were going to be coming up in the future with these particular menin inhibitors.
They looked at not only what they are expecting the new mutations to be, but then looked at how
these drugs responded to the new mutations. And you can see based on where these mutations are,
some of them bind a little bit more closely to where each of these menin inhibitors bind to.
And so this is going to be published in about two weeks in Nature Communications. And I think
it's going to be a really interesting article to sort of think about how we either are going
to sequence these medications or in combination, do we actually see that these mutations
are going to be coming back to us or not. And so I think it's going to be a really interesting
article to sort of think about how we either are going to see these mutations or not.
And then this is sort of the next step in this, which is going to be the phase three trial.
There's going to be a Blexi/Beneza versus, and then there's also going to be a triplet
as well with seven plus three. It's going to be randomized as well.
So I think those are going to be very important to try to determine,
is it actually effective? The randomized trials are always the most important. And so in conclusion,
it's a very potent oral menin inhibitor that affects both NPM1 and KMT2A. And there is some
question of enhanced T cell toxicity, which could be important down the road.
There's single agent data, which shows really low side effects, including low
incidence of differentiation syndrome and intriguing responses as single agents.
There's definitely data for combination with venetoclax or with azaven and also with
intensive chemotherapy, because we still think about intensive chemotherapy for these NPM1
mutations. We'll see where that goes according to Dr. Pearl and where we go with the next paradigm
study. But preliminary data said that there may be some benefit in these with Blexi/Beneza and some
of the mutations that we see. And that's going to be the next step that we think about as we
kind of go down this road of multiple drugs with similar targets, kind of like what we did with
CML mutations as well. And so thank you all very much for the invite. Thank you for your time.
Okay.